Here's something nobody warns you about
when you start building agents alone.
You think you're building prompts. You
think your building skills are
worthless. If you build long enough,
specially alone,
you will start building something
completely different.
Something that looks suspiciously like
CICD. Except worse, because you're
building it from scratch, one failure at
a time. I'm Sumaiya. I run a 19 skill
cloud code agent system.
Writing, research, vault sync, analytics
sync, hook, transcript, and many more.
And the most useful thing I learned from
building this was not how to build
better prompts. It was recognizing the
five controls I was rebuilding badly and
what you can do instead. Before I show
you the problem, let me show you the
system that taught me the problem.
This is the agent content system. It is
open source. Link in the description.
It runs every other Saturday. It reads
from a knowledge vault, creates a
research brief, builds content plan,
produces 12 content pieces, then runs
verify passes, reviewer gates,
deduplication, and finally saves the
output as markdown files. But here's the
thing that matters for this talk, not
the content. What matters is that this
system has seven handoffs. Scheduler to
command, command to research, research
to content content plan to production
production skill to verifier, verifier
to reviewer, reviewer to the output
folder. Every single handoff is the
place where the system can lie to you.
And if you're building the system alone,
nobody catches the lies except you,
usually after the damage is done. Here's
the pattern I want you to watch for in
your own systems. If you build agents
independently, you will rebuild these
five things roughly in this order.
You change a prompt or a skill, and
something downstream breaks.
So, you build a way to test whether the
output still matches the expected shape.
Congratulations, you have reinvented
regression testing.
So, you set up a cron job or scheduled
task. One day, it silently fails, but
you haven't noticed for a week.
So, you build alerts.
You just reinvented CI monitoring.
One skill changes its output schema, so
three skills downstream break.
You decided to add a validation at the
boundary because of it.
You just reinvented contract testing. An
artifact looks done, but it shouldn't
ship. So, you add a checkpoint before it
goes to the ready folder.
You just reinvented staging
environments.
Something goes wrong, but you cannot
find out which prompt, which skill, or
which handoff had the bad output. So,
you start logging everything.
You just reinvented audit trails.
The reason the title says worst version
isn't because agents are software
builds, it's because you end up needing
the exact same operational guarantees.
However, the agent systems give you none
of it by default.
So, you build them independently.
The worst version.
Without even realizing that you're
building it. The dangerous failure in an
agent system is never a bad output.
A bad output is very easy to fix. You
glance at it, and immediately you can
understand it's a bad output. The
dangerous failure is a polished artifact
that looks great at a glance. However,
it will never pass your exit gates. It
uses the wrong voice pattern. It makes
an unverified claim. It repeats an old
angle. It's missing required sections,
and it gets leveled ready to publish
anyway. That is the agent equivalent of
shipping because the code compiled, but
the tests never run.
This is what I'm going to demo for you.
Not the happy path, but the three ways
the agent can lie to you and the gates
to catch it. Let me start with the happy
path because this is what all agent
demos show you.
I'm going to run a small privacy-safe
version of my content engine pipeline.
This isn't the full repo. It's a
distilled version of the production
problem. The pipeline is simple.
Generate a content artifact, run gates,
and either allow or block the output.
Look at the output.
The markdown has a caption, pinned
comment, visual brief, verification log,
vault assets, production notes,
and a ready status. If I demo only this,
the system looks done.
The artifact looks professional. The
content reads well. This is why agent
demos are misleading. They always show
you the happy path. But what happens if
the path is not happy, but the output
still looks ready? Now, let's look at
the failure number one, voice drift.
Look at the content. Unlock the power of
AI adoption. This game-changer will
transform how teams operate in today's
fast-paced enterprise landscape.
If you have spent enough time on
LinkedIn, you have seen this exact same
sentence thousands of times. It's
generic AI marketing language.
It's not my voice. It's not your voice.
It's nobody's voice.
But, knife mode saved it anyway. Because
the artifact has all the required
sections. It has a ready status, and it
looks complete. Now, what what happens
when I add one boundary? Guarded mode
blocks it at the voice contract. The
pipeline stops before this artifact
enters the publish ready folder. This is
the point. The gate doesn't make the
content better. If you're building a
content system, this is the first gate I
would recommend. If you're building any
other agent system, the equivalent
question is, what does wrong voice looks
like in your domain? Failure number two
is missing verification. This piece
says, "Teams with a clear semantic
ownership model reduce AI rollout rework
by 37%."
37%.
This is a very specific claim.
Where did it come from? Check the
verification log. It's empty. The prose
is usable. The number sounds plausible.
That's what makes the failure dangerous.
A confident sounding claim without any
verification or reference. And knife
mode saved it. Guarded mode blocks it.
Claim bearing content cannot ship
without a verification trail.
"Trust me" is not a verifier. If your
agent system makes claims about data,
about users, about anything, and you
don't have a validation chain, you're
shipping unverified assertions with a
professional looking wrapper. That's not
an agent problem. That's a credibility
problem. Failure three, duplication
hook. This is my favorite failure,
because this is the most realistic one
for solo builders. The output is new.
The content looks technically coherent.
But, the hook, the opening angle, is a
near duplicate of something from your
vault history. Yeah, adoption fails when
the dashboards looks right, but the
workflow is wrong. That angle has
already been used. If your system keeps
generating near duplicates, your system
looks automated, even if every
individual piece is technically fine.
Your audience notices before you do.
Garden mode blocks it at the data
contract. I noticed this.
It also wrote an audit record.
That audit record is boring, but when a
scheduled run fails at 2:00 a.m., the
final artifact alone is not enough. You
need to know which gate failed. Which
contract was violated and why? That's
the audit trail, the fifth reinvention.
And that's the one most solid builders
had lost
after the damage has already been done.
So, what's the pattern here?
You don't need a platform. You don't
need a framework. You don't need the
ecosystem to catch up.
What you need are a few boring gates. A
pre-save output contract. Does the
artifact have the required shape before
it's saved?
A voice or domain contract. Does the
output match the rules your system was
designed around?
A voice or domain contract. Does the
output match the rules your system was
designed around? A verification
contract. If the output makes claims,
can those claims be traced to a source?
A deduplication check.
Is this genuinely new? Or is the system
recycling itself? An audit trail. When
something fails, can you reconstruct
what happened without rewriting the
entire pipeline? In software, we learned
not to deploy only because code exists.
In agent systems, we need to learn not
to ship just because the artifacts look
complete. The problem is not your agent
will fail.
Your agent will fail. The problem is
when your system farmers that failure
nicely and ships it downstream. Here's
what I want you to take away. Map your
handoffs from input to the final output.
Every arrow between two steps can be a
place where the output gets corrupted.
You don't have to fix all of them. You
just have to know where they are. Pick
the most expensive handoff. Not the most
complex, most expensive. The one where
bad data can cost you the most. A wrong
claim published publicly, a broken
schema that cascades to three downstream
skills, a duplicate that errors your
audience's trust. That's where your
first gate goes. Make it say no.
A gate which logs only warnings is not a
gate.
It's a suggestion. The gate needs to
block the artifact from moving forward.
That's the difference between an
impressive demo and an operable system.
Before you add another agent, add one
boundary.
Thank you for watching.